so I want to this is something that I
had indicated in my first tutorial now I
want to make it precise the connection
between the prover theory and orbit
closure of the determinant basically all
in one line all Newton degenerations as
a defined in the first tutorial of
Semyon events of the skipper's would be
sitting on the orbit closure of the
determinant and when the things are tame
you can expect kind of polynomial time
theory of edmonds but when the things
are wild things can go while and that is
what causes the complexity of the orbit
closure of the determinant to shut up
and so as I had indicated so I just want
to make that that was one gap in the
first tutorial so I just want to fix it
sorry call
it Z be symbolic determinants of size
symbolic determinate we mean that it
just misses size you have a environment
where each entry is any combination of
the very linear form of x1 to xn and
then you take the determinant of Z and
you express it as monomials in Z alpha
so let us say C alpha Z alpha whether
these are the monomial sins
then you define the Newton of Z yeah
yeah XL five mins j's ma darkness and
yeah you can dig some indices here okay
in the Newton of Z by that we just mean
the Newton polytope of Z just take all
these exponents and take the conviction
and given any phase even any phase
inside the Newton of Z so you define the
Newton degeneration with respect to that
phase Newton degeneration we denote it
like this if z will be equal to C alpha
x alpha and you just range range alpha /
or the things that occur in the face ok
fixing your thumbs any anything yet via
but fixed you're not very good linear
forms yeah yeah i think the permanent
versus determinants a similar thing okay
and the determinant coefficient is not 0
for all the entries or just above the
determinant Newton polytope of Z your
the determinant you just take the
exponents mercy alphas are nonzero
determinant yes he's right expand CI
polynomial that computes of indiana not
the determinant of Z Z has linear forms
in the excess and it's capped out at the
crazy for insomnia in the exit and you
just take them are males or to see okay
loses something is that is both the
matrix and in a polynomial yeah yeah I'm
just I should have written Newton of
diggsy etc if you want that
a Newton degeneration is for any face in
the Newton polytope not necessarily
facet you just choose those alphas which
occur in a few just truncate it there
okay and point is that this occurs in
the orbit closure of the determinant em
that we saw because you can just
whatever okay so it occurs and the
question now is when does determinant F
have a small size okay question when
does determinant if Z have a small size
small circuit that is a circuit of
polynomial size okay that is the
question and the conjecture was not
always and there was a complexity
theoretical wizzen for that because of
licks atithi erotic reason where that
first of all
that even Z and alpha deciding if X
alpha occurs and Z is hard very hard
actually as hard as so I won't go into
this as hard as deciding if the
determinant of a if the permanent of a
given matrix is equal to some fixed
value given in binary very hard as hard
as computing the permanent basically it
says and to hear membership problem
problem for the newton polytope of Z is
also is also hard is P heart which means
given any rational point deciding
whether it is in that Newton polytope is
a hard problem okay in general so the
number the space as such and how does
that compare inch size with the space of
face of what space a foot race Oh s
and space of small circles what do you
mean my space of it you mean this this
this cardinality of this yeah so in
general the choices are app versus yeah
so the choice of f so generally what you
would want is that if this is hard what
this says is that this would kind of
behave kind of randomly and now you have
to choose f's so that the number of
alphas in that is exponential okay I
mean you can choose F so that the it has
exponentially many vertices and there if
this kind of things go randomly the the
circuit size would shut up that is the
inclusion yeah so you want you to take a
core dimensional spaces I don't know any
any face yeah yeah yeah but you should
have exponentially mini face
exponentially many vertices on it yeah
so the thing so for example so the
problem is you want some specific
families where you would detect the
problem okay so this problem is so
construct some specific Z is ok to
construct specific zzz that we want to
construct using Weaver Theory theory for
which this kind of behavior which
complexity theory suggests should occur
for which
determinants FZ does not have a small
circuit all phases of the Newton pollito
okay and it would be basically the same
Ian variants of wild viewers what jersey
was talking about so so now let me say
the Q is a river without oriented cycles
and you can have possibly involutions
also here though he didn't talk about it
you can have involutions and then you
have similar theory and then given
dimension vector beta and any
representation e of the Cure with
dimension vector alpha with dimension so
let see elf cv okay in the semi
invariant in what he denoted as s I of
QB okay Semyon variant of that okay so
which is basically this definition the
ring of so if you take all the
representation space of representations
which dimension vector b c and then you
take the whatever SL QB the take the j
election on that and
so you can identify that with slq be
kind of the space at listening so this
is the same you arrant and now with this
basically we so late it is the node q be
the total number of total number of
nodes and arrows in the in the grass the
total size of the graph and you let
alpha equal to summation alpha I and
beta equal to summation because I the
total size of the dimensional vectors
then notice that from the definition
that he gave that CV is a witch to make
it precise we will also denote sometime
the cv q alpha b beta is a symbolic
determinant symbolic determinant only
determinant of size that is polynomial
in off sighs that is polynomial in the
duck in the size of the quiver and the
sizes of the dimension McGraw once and
for all yeah right now yeah first hey
you know the one with a six and one
preferred all the others had arrows
going into it makes it three just take
the same good enough this is this is a
bad fever already
ok so now now what you can do is with
this cleaver you can of course and you
notice subclass of VP associated with
this fixed quiver and it would be
basically so this basically is the set
of all know now this symbolic
determinant would basically be the
symbolic determinant coming from that CV
ok in the construction of cv he
constructed that determinant wreck yeah
so that is that Z going to be now ok ok
so the the set of symbolic determinant
families of the form
so basically you just take all of this
kind the symbolic determinant family of
the form Q alpha beta okay so this would
have the number of variables here okay
so the number of variables here number
of variables will be equal to basically
the dimension of the representation
space q be so which would be less than
total being a square okay so you so you
would want that q plus alpha plus beta
is less than some fixed polynomial in n
as you do in the in the in the
complexity class definition of a
fearsome fixed polynomial and you also
want that Q and beta square is less than
or equal to n so that the number of
variables is more than what is required
to describe the matrices in that okay so
so that gives you some family of this
thing and so that is the number of
arrows and number of rows and arrows in
every value yeah yeah they would always
now you're all in valiant word because
all these are symbolic determinants okay
and then you define the Newton
degeneration of these to be basically
then you take all these Newton
degeneration they won't be in the
valiant world anymore they would be in
the orbit closure okay so if you take
the Newton degeneration of VP then they
will they would be inside VP bar okay
you are taking orbit closures okay
because all these Newton degeneration
belong to the orbit closure of the
determiner and so now the question is so
the in complexity theory questions is
when is Newton
PQ inside VP okay when I bend you
literally live in the valiant world and
when you live outside okay based on the
quiver that is a question and the
conjecture would be that if and only if
and you are always assuming that Q is
without oriented sigerson this is
required for some reason technical
reasons I won't go into without oriented
cycles okay Victor would be if and only
if Q is theme yeah finite is considered
tape whatever yeah oh yeah I find it
depending upon how you define tame I
mean some people think of finite as the
domestic or something there's an MA
store domestic observe and how are going
through a weird terminology sir so okay
so let me take the simplest example so
the simplest team cleaver would
correspond to what I would say is was
the origin of actually the complexity
class p okay and through that
essentially it would require
generalizing edmonds theory to all train
covers which is already would be quite a
I think important thing and the thing is
basically what the conjugate is saying
that Edmunds theory won't generalize to
wild viewers but to tame squivers it
would okay so that is basically what
what it is saying okay so take the
simplest case tame case so take you to
be one thing with this in Malaysian okay
so if you don't take in knowledge and
then the and then the generator is just
the determinant of X which is showed and
if you have this involution then the
generator would be the square root of so
you take the matrix where you have zij
here and minus Zi
okay so this is the skew symmetric
matrix and each square root is what is
called the fashion that would generate
the same univ entering in this case now
so in this case the Newton polytope of
square root of G is precisely the
perfect matching positive perfect
matching polytope of of the complete
graph on whatever there are two in one
on two n nodes okay it is exactly the
perfect matching politic of the complete
graph onto n nodes and for these edmonds
and so this is actually an important
thing about complexity theory which I
think I won't I mean this is some JaVale
of complexity theory in fact was the
origin so I wanted to convey this to
mathematician this is what needs to be
now generalized to our retreat in
Reverse so eight months this is a
fundamental result of advanced
first that Newton z in that case okay is
defined by 0z i j less than or equal to
1 then you have for all I you have that
z IJ you sum over j is equal to 1 this
is kind of obvious you would say obvious
constraints because it is a perfect
matching polytope it just says that
every h 0 or 1 here it says that for
every vertex you are actually you would
have to list one thing going but what is
not obvious is this third constraint is
that for for any odd subset t of 2n so
take all edges which belong to the co
boundary of T that is if you are taking
this is your 2 n nodes and if you take
any or subset then basically some edge
ok in the matching has to come out ok so
basically it says that this zi j is
greater than or equal to 1 and using
this so there are exponentially many
such constraint and the amazing thing is
that he actually showed that the the
membership question is in p ok and this
actually is actually the birth of in
some sense okay and using that is
exponentially many facets yeah that is a
miracle okay and that is in some sense
the first non trivial and and using that
then of course he also gave a polynomial
time algorithm for finding minimum
weight but perfect matching in in a
graph and that is actually in some since
the beginning of P theory of P okay no
it's not it's really not about highly
non-trivial this is the beginning of
complexity theory okay I mean this is a
seat huh
yeah but this is the this is but he
defined so actually he motivated this is
where complexity class p is so important
so so this actually and the membership
membership problem or Newton see belongs
to pee okay and now what kia has shown
is that in that case the newton
degeneration so this is theorem cure and
this is basically because it has some
kind of miraculous description that in
that case it would follow the
determinant of FZ has a small circuit
circuit for every f in the newton
politic ok
and it actually crucially depends on
these Edmunds kinds of constraints so
the point is if you have constraints
very special so that the membership
problem is easy then you can kind of
expect membership problem is easy and in
that case this problem is also is it
deciding a monomial occurs in it is just
basically deciding if alpha corresponds
to a perfect matching which is easy okay
so if these two basic questions
associated with the Newton pollito
parise then you can kind of kind of
expect a Edmonds theory so so the
problem here would be so basically what
the conjecture says is that this so so
the main problem here is
just to clarify the membership problem
is non-trivial I mean first of all you
require that description and then you
get this like the convex combinations of
yeah no no it doesn't have to be 0 1
could be any rational point yeah yeah
and this is actually the basic Oracle
like if you see all this in if you look
at the ellipsoid algorithm for the for
constructing minimum it perfect matching
this is the basic Oracle that you would
use in the ellipsoid algorithm so this
is really the heart of the matter in
sense this is why everything connected
with this is in actually p because of
membership Oleg and also you it gives
you a separating hyperplane on language
don't directly check these exponentially
maybe but if constraints but if one
friends you can find not all of them are
satisfied it is possible to efficiently
find one one one that is the whole point
okay so you have to have that kind of
structure to it then if you have that
kind of structure then KO tells you that
actually determinant if has a small size
for everything because of that specific
structure but in general such a
structure is not going to be there so
make sure that the KO axis theorem in
algebra complexed it's about arithmetic
circuit well as the atmosphere amazing
bulan complexion yeah yeah but it is the
heart of the roof pointing out that
there is a difference between the
occupied zone
actually and there is a this small
circuit right now the weed we can't
actually given if you can't actually
find the small circuit efficiently
because it's actually the problem of D
randomization okay so you are in a loop
there but it exists okay it exists so
the problem is so the wind so yeah so I
said that so when I when you say the
conjecture is that the Newton of v PQ is
inside VP if and only if Q is is finite
or 10 so basically what it means is that
when q is finite or tame you have to
actually show first of all for example
that the membership problem is easy and
so forth okay so that would basically
generalize Edmund Siri to any quiver of
Tim type which would be very very
interesting and the everybody knows in
complexity theory that Edmonds result
was in miracle I mean you don't expect
such miracles to happen and when the
things are wild we are not expecting
that to happen and
this that is activation the compelling
and the prob and the thing that
membership problem for newton version of
the polytope and the polynomial time
algorithm to solve the municipal so so
we expect that that would hold for any
team player so i think that is one
intermediate thing to work on and not so
so what does that mean so so the problem
is that all of the occurrence so in
general it won't they would be an X so
what that means is that you have this
orbit closure of the determinant
wondering if you checked so as monster
soon maybe its first miracle Danny it
must put some other miracles about which
generalizes tomato its Polly metroids
but also there is a polynomial these
come from Quivers also maybe I think
that is that and that I think is worth
worth checking ok ok so the other yeah I
think obvious made a point so the
edmonds and Louis also I think Louis
actually has generalized this to various
kinds of Metroid so the thing is do they
correspond to any kind of fevers and
then try to generalize that matching
theory to arboretum cover so that is the
thing there is also another how to say
which i think i must say mentioned in it
that's a theorem of stuff yeah oh so I
mean it's okay i get a pretty basic
paper so we give zoom section shows so
that had previously shown if you want
the matching is equality yeah a view a
sufficient condition is they become a
checkbook so where how does this say
reflecting these sir perhaps what I'm
asking is
so before you develop you do that yes
yeah secret top start tearin for pimp
reversing temper yeah so you know no I I
don't that's why I'm asking you I don't
know but I believe that that's a that's
a reasonable now what does it mean
that's him i will not say the D disease
but it's very easy to say when the
person was beautiful day if it asks what
happens if you solve any number of
vertices in the graph the graph splits
how many if the connected components or
even on how many are there that that's
the only condition that you looking I
think I don't know just have you seen
any such things studied in viewer theory
over there because I think harm Dirksen
has some papers on the variance of
Metroid no no I'm asking around taxis
earlier today yeah so it says they let
me say it's not so complicated a graph
is a perfect matching if and only reason
so the only type of obstruction per
perfect matchings is that you can throw
a let's say some number n vertices and
there are more than a connected
components of old Odom that's anything
only with distinction the interval graph
right here
no I mean they should be but it would
take some I mean I think the thing has
not been studied and there is much to be
done here something I mean in hindsight
you understand there's something only
way to get to understand yeah start I
mean if you don't understand domestic
animals we are not going to understand y
equals look at me this is this is
actually the simplest tame and finite
type okay the domestic case okay so what
I am saying is what this says that all
these wild rays are actually occurring
here okay and this is why this is why
actually the NLL currently is in X space
okay so this is why the complexity of
nal currently is so high and as I said
that the positive thing is what you
think is that in spite of all these wild
thing sitting on the thing so the
positive things so the negative thing is
that all these wild things are sitting
on the orbit closure of the determinant
because of that there is an exponential
blow-up in the circuit sizes because of
that this problem in an ill so the
negative thing is negative is that nll
for this delta n is currently in express
is currently in express and we do not
know how to get it to even x because of
these problems because of this basically
so in complexity theory we simply have
no idea of how to get X you know right
now there are exponential size circuits
you have to just cycle through all of
them and that requires expression you
can do cycling through by Grovner mrs.
theory and all that but we don't know
anything better than that written but
the positive thing is that if the GCT
one conjecture is true in ignoring quasi
factor nll belongs to Kwazii debt it can
come down from space to date which is a
huge thing which is basically the
difficulty of the problem right now and
that is very beyond so I think some open
problems first that we should work on
first in this time
improvers try to remnants theory here I
think that would already give us some
understanding then second I I said was
that equivalence problem and NN l4v
Margie arbitrary without any restriction
on the dimension on g belongs to pee
that would be the second intermediate
problem and the third problem is the
chronic and problem belongs to pee I
think if we understand these three
problems on the way in this program we
have made a lot of progress I mean we
are still very far from understanding
orbit closure of the determinant but
there is already lot on our plate before
we can really hope to understand all
that so I think with that let me stop
and now we can have discussion on what
to do next and so forth so open
satellite I foolishly spend time
discussing open questions I mean there's
three maybe people could suggest some
more yeah yeah yeahs very interested ok
yeah yeah I wasn't sure what the moment
of this would be but I mean not right
from obviously things I want to talk
about two things which already came up
so one is the point is beating granny
audience at this and many of them or
anywhere really in point more like the
terminal it hardened we should
understand the objects and simpler for
nahmias and if you think the point of
view it does not complexity theory we
cannot even move lower down fall in the
hook like this we have what's up in our
forum well these are a fine the first we
know possible that the German say 10 or
even terminate them it's much more
outrageous than during the manager is
possible that you can embed them with
the you know just any things here were
any boolean the solid we know you can
compute the terminal and permanent just
by a formula of polynomial side of depth
Lee which replaces and just has a fine
forms in there in the body it's
outrageous and we should pull thatthat's
impossible so we don't know how to so
let me give you an example problem photo
from the fact that the remedy symmetric
polynomials and by basically wanted to
start this
as opposed to the term your biz closure
of cisco exactly but you understood
community is mine everyone on the team
and find it well am that are fine sorry
because I have to allow I thought it
turned out that you know these are
polynomials with your complicated i have
exponentially many monomials but
nevertheless they the very simple the
very simple formula like this the
waveform super popular with so despite
the fact that this is complicated for
the army'll I mean I told you this so
what I can show because of that and even
easier question to ask is the you're
answering email java Oregon sorry yes
come on fire I cannot travel gotta
stretch more death but I can just little
between sentence then I can show you
because because this can be done and
even easier question to ask is can you
embed the terminal terminal with a
favorite for now it not it to this but
just into semantics into the symmetric
for number lost in our forum so can your
wife death and as symmetric elementary
somatic polynomial
some K&N from heaven am of something out
for me to survive but for this is an M
by M matrix why this would be my honor
of the line what kind of lower bounds
and kami make you happy what are
polynomials you cannot do it for n NK
polynomials in it yeah well cave less
than n so you cannot put for n which is
for long lisa is a fine forms it's very
important that they are fine java talks
about the method of partial derivatives
which is a baby version of everything
that earlier was doing something
enormous and i did long ago you can use
it to show that if your receipt yourself
Lou homogeneous uniform without concern
then there is an exponential door bound
on embedding given the terminal even to
this but once you are now constants and
how I answer your question because you
see the power of constant you can for
Naga size formula sports is they are not
responsible determinants maybe I don't
know
just want to fail this is just a
question of whether whether the
determinant is contained in them is
contained in the action of the fine
group on acting on the symmetric even so
we we just as we want to understand
whether you can is the same kind of
question you keep asking I mean the
whole week we were asking about the
terminal is a much simpler for your
mother I don't think Molina orbit
Claudette object doesn't contain any
nasty spill yes sir it's a great
question whether your conjecture about
the of it those are one funny I mean
yeah yeah I show you especially is a
great conjecture which affect our show
the disclosure of not have anyone saw me
they are all the things in the closure
of small circle yeah I don't know why I
think it makes sense i fly i know i
don't think it would be easy but you
know I think it's much more doable than
for the tournament so so I'm suggesting
this may i c-couldn't notation does in
me anymore where n is polynomial in
there so you want to show this and what
did I end what kind of group oh this
just a fine group so you I know its
Alicia and I'm so if you just what this
is the way I like to express it just
like I write it further as you met a
function of applying for an elementary
symmetric function elemental asymmetric
fun one of the elementary students
we will no loss of the holidays I think
the other similar thing is that for
diagonal entry circuit which a young
German is Nova does not contain one move
in the services yeah I should have
mentioned that even simpler observe when
the metal is symmetric polynomials are
just a diagonal some of power and for
that we never we have low newport on the
boundary on the boundary i don't know
actually yeah that's less stuff from the
model is one so maybe we fake rephrase
your question about characters of
jiangsu they seem a shooter shoot
polynomial so when they on diagram eyes
only o sir n dick the determinant a
zombie one column know it is this ok
yeah for me it's less natural but maybe
for you it's more than to help think
about it this way anyway yeah so they're
simple for nahmias to study and study
that frozen zone now for those who want
to see this is sort of this magic but
it's very simple pro here to serve it
comes from the fact that you all know
that if i take someone but my variable
x1 right i wanted one of the elementary
symmetric polynomials in it and compute
the mall in fact so i take some variable
T and I look at this bonus 31 it just
simply the sum of the metric ok and you
so this is that in the F time that's
obvious but that way this is this is the
circuit you see the circuit so there the
multiplication gate I'll tell you what
they initially so we'll have n plus 1
multiplication game or we look like this
fateful day you take this will be
responsible for people see we are going
to do interpolation free like though DX
IC x minus xn here i do i multiply 1
plus x 1 1 plus s m and here i multiply
and I need that feel to be larger than I
I told just evaluate this for different
values of T now what do I put you where
if I have of these values their
evaluations of this as n plus 1 points
or anything k I can tell you what you
know there is something is largely by
fighting squad it's a nice word size
formula I don't understand
ask us to determine and there's a
symmetric so normally media woman you
just say they love that that's hot yeah
no time what I'm saying this is the way
to do the symmetric elementary symmetric
once and I want you to show that nothing
like this could work all I shall not be
no permeability yeah I am down you can
notice that you know that in all forms
of just you know slice too so you can
start like we always stop these are
problems and cleitus they will maybe
maybe 20 30 front son it cannot be done
and liturgy has a new alone showing that
if this is small less a constant is it
was responsible but this expansion rope
on the breaks down when the fun hey just
was one I wanted to just study simply
reduction school to simpler polynomial
the other thing I mentioned during yoga
stocks I'm not good working with you
down I just say it again all the noble
methods which succeeded for some classes
of circuits where ever you know common
framework the common framework is that
you take
all the ones that were successful I also
many of the one that out of it Joseph
described as out being attempted by
various people of his young flattening
the hobby of things they play the the
same form they take if we take I'm not
peace and variables and the gritty so
these are all polynomials polynomials
and vows valuable homogeneous of degree
I know you like this deal but it doesn't
matter anyway we have this space and we
take Helene our mapping from this to
suffer the way we prove your bounce in
ways we let sit for you know for
polynomial P we want to say that the
dimension of lfp is bigger than the
dimension of anything trying to compute
if it can be a family of circuits it can
be the closure of the terminal Thunder
you know it's just a search of a also it
bigger than that dimension I love you
both you in some class which is what we
attract the lava that's how they work I
think it's a great presence also partial
derivatives like this is shifted ones
are like the chief massager derivatives
and the project achieve the partial
derivatives are lighter than they are
slept in inside like that and so there's
an average and I can do
image campaign on my drop no no no not a
sir no sir but that's how the post work
it is a regeneration convention but
anyway you slice to do something I
business and one question I don't know
the answer 20 it's a great question i
think the feeling i am i have and maybe
just for the show the same feeling is
that they now next may not be enough so
it's a you know it would be a great
person to say that no matter what dinner
is just studied in complete geology no
matter what's in our max you can you
cannot use it to separate permanent from
the term looking anomaly remember that
dimension quality leave everything and
to my face exactly my ring back so she
say if you have a nonlinear map of that
property then you go to the tangent
space you would really using a linear
yeah so why are even Molly and might get
it completely changing to linear my
going to symmetric power yeah well I
thing but I think what I'll do it's
hidden in hobby didn't say is there's
this determinant oh yeah because women
with mini around trees you're the unit
to whether you are leaving the comments
we're doing our whole program has such
formula go just you know translations of
the term hands of small size for know me
aside then yeah so you can study
pacifically specific question I didn't
think about so maybe I'm not taking his
life but something like that doesn't
exist AM L for waking the dimension
of the tournament or you need actually
the government is bigger then as I
mention of anything in the obese Clause
of the of the determination and viable
for any in any map which with the finish
I don't know I mean that's a complete
question and this see like that it's not
the same question to move to unite right
replaced by some porn argument and I
don't know what to do given me the
polynomial map and it will not be a
vector space what's open sorry yeah I
never so truly truly chicken up with
swings and vehement yes but not really
just just by definition the an idea i
should say what it is mad we have some
fixed that verification what we are
mapping yeah we are mapping for numbers
two subspaces that's what happens you
know this is not a family so yeah does a
complete question maybe it's not
but the way that works is that that sort
of continuous polynomial yeah so so on
remember five workers well yes I'm happy
you have somebody I should kick alien
mind with a greater good no I want and
the original kill me i don't know maybe
there's no idea i mean i don't know but
what I think I mean they really
complacent allegedly come which we are a
very obviously be selective all signs in
that when we fail to pull something we
try to a look for the reason namely boo
that all the methods really so far faith
there's a history of such things and
some of you have met a force and
invitations very certain like this so
this will be mainly this is not this
technique general no matter what kind of
you know algebraic geometric intuition
you mean our is nothing I don't know
slow increments assumptions well I was
gonna mention across from pick up yeah I
think I can say it froze right chelators
oh it's too bad because Mike black urban
will be here but he's not here at the
moment this is really question for him
so there's this farm right about a egg
which is just a deep powers
and then you have this symmetric order
rank which is the smallest are that are
the wearing red p the smallest soapy
polynomial the smallest are such that it
is some excellent the G so this is let's
call that are and then we have our
underbar as well as are such a p is a
limit of like this so these are things
that right have most right are these are
things of it rank order right car and
the question is how to how different in
these two numbers be so there exists
this does there exist a sequence
e.j where the growth of PJ is is greater
than a polynomial in the growth of the
border rank and the conjecture is no um
so the Nexus should on site hmm no they
do not coincide in general so so the
border rank and so if i look at the
polynomial x x squared X to the D minus
1 wide right that has bordering the two
and rank equal to what is it d minus 1
or D minus V over to something like that
d D D ant I knew it was something like
that so here you have two ND so they
could be very different but still d is
rose like a polynomial polynomial in two
all right so I have to make the question
why is it so big i think is intelligent
win the number of video was it yeah so
some polynomial indian number of video
oh whatever it has to make besides yeah
no i agree right yeah it should be paid
my buddies so you know so much otherwise
it dancer thanks yeah so let's see it so
we have n number of variables and team
let's just set that equal to date
without any loss of generality so we
have only have one forever to worry
about and so what we want is a big gap a
gap between these two that grows faster
than polynomial so far from pj minus r
of pj keeps the hydration yeah yeah yeah
I'm get there what's the another mic
that I'll have it's dead precisely
what's the these rings for him it's
completely unknown the only thing that I
mine and of course you need that mean
the bigger one help but the bigger one
excellent rank the maximum rank is known
to be at most twice the maximum border
rank so but of course the maximum border
rank can grow exponentially fast and n
so you want to so if there's going to be
a counterexample it's going to be
something of smallish border rank where
the rank is close to maximal that's
that's the idea dude or so so so what's
the maximum rank was it was that I told
you the only thing that's known as its
most twice the Mexico border right and
the maximal border rank is this you know
it was you minus 1 choose d / what and
what do you want yes my mom died it
isolated on the minimum Bob Bauder bank
and the maximum right right right
Horatio guys alive and that grow very
fast question he believes no I think
that's reasonable and I think this is a
very clean question in algebraic
geometry that we could work on
I have question about about this K P and
P I mean that's motivated in part by
your results on little with your
choosing coefficients this is there any
other reason besides besides just hope
that it would be okay Eve knock AT&T
yeah yeah but the intuition comes from
the previous yeah yeah my intuition I
mean not London p if the secretary
vegetable this is actually in something
here form of that because here you know
you have to battle me all the other on
the okay this is not specifically then I
think that it's going to be the empty
stack that is not even if I could hear
it it's the cavitation you werent here
okay what I'm saying is that the things
that has talked about which none of us
want to happen would happen and I don't
think I think that none of those things
would happen
yeah like in this topic like a very big
field in the black stick with the final
ml engage with your organization and
it's like instant Agra severus which not
normal but it shows if you know how to
make a number then stacey account to
make the randomization you can separate
carbon from determine its not be formal
and they won't take to note one very
nice a very nice program in the
generalization so problem is the college
humor to have a paranormal your ad in 10
on kill excel and they want to find one
concrete polynomial which is not 0 not
identically zero on any subspace of you
mention say tell what's the minimal
degree of this polynomial can you find
so arena will be cheat I want to find
binomial and variable so attachment for
every for every vector space
crazy fun right you mention say in my
opinion is very very clean equation like
dementia so making dimension argument
one can show that various to thank
binomial one can so it doesn't mean it
is just business so once you get their
generic follow happen yeah generic
phenomenal progress property now like
we're so what yes the game this was it
if you grab it consolidates the movie
moderate as I countries are they heading
to the power 1 by Ken yes dimensions
arguments a with generic but what happen
with the symmetric elemental symmetric
polynomial of degree 11 its you'll be
here you can show or what on some
it's maybe not trivial to see to find
subspace but like you can solve these
two small like degrees less than enters
I above the above the old dimension one
above you of them know what he says in
to do one thing I know but I'm giving an
even lower cheek even if it's lower you
can solve it there is no nothing I can
show proof and it is actually dimension
argument because if you work over
complex numbers who can show it to not
notice play another game and like reason
reason why we need a size decrease
because it's a loop site on POF lambda 1
V you expanded as polynomial in lambda
sample normal hi i1 equal to DM I 0 some
polynomials p GI you look spending this
way and it's 0 even only if I all these
polynomials are 0 at some point like
this if you want then until all these
polynomials you can find like some some
point some you want me to return such an
obvious panel video so you cannot take
it's too small and but we can take you
can find such polynomial like you can
swap it for generically for genetically
generikb mmlv degree will curb this
property and it looks very clean
question and you'll have like mega big
implications like in a given relation
open a meld education for color
correcting codes like like there are
many hours questions is so far if
dimension was not 10 but but one you
would take the moment yes then donation
one can solve it and for dimension to
you can also call not more
I work or even though it's over so I
mean I'm in this position it happens
it's if there's some degree what happens
and Anna Jennifer because because you
could use it so much for ventus to come
tonight whenever but questioner to find
like to find one and to prove for which
month with its not be icic had to find a
lot of screen readers can occur come on
it's very good hey nice yeah okay so
much me an explicit so it says equation
we those discussed many times in any
sense like in any sense which is soup so
let's say find anybody level but don't
say generic by the next Pentonville is
not expedient dimension argument is not
allowed dimension or random arguments
are not alone yeah but it's okay it's
okay I'm so sure like whereas many ways
or like some algorithm we tried each
monomial in polynomial time but I think
in many people use I think in shallow
the circuit it's like Maria why it's in
people I down the coefficients what we
call Fisher University only find where
BNP uniform game villain Julia
no no I efficient you can write done
efficiently you can write down
coefficient position not allow you to
make click like taking coefficient by
chrisy irrational numbers or you know so
no no cheating like this like authentic
coefficients which are yo is au niveau
leap on BNP it would you like permanent
yeah monitors exponentially many
monomial but it's not a problem to know
what it is born have you tried asking
neighbors does he even talked about and
about the nation and a photographer pana
schemes in hyper services and this is a
question when ok this way I'm thought of
asking this question now because I'm
know they turn left today morning
because this is a question it's for
finding my diaper service with empty
fanos I'm good but right now down the
resolutions kind of scheme is you know
by brett i would talk about allowing
your idea if there's some you know there
could be some interesting lineare
section or manipulation one could do to
the permit to kill it silence key that
would be a way take their papers the
starting point you look at where those
fan of schemes come from because they
know where they come from in some cases
for a minute and then you try to kill
those off one by one by altering the
permanent that would be one strength I
don't know presents responsible morning
Nathan told me that like other schemes
of Piper's purposes our stuff oh yeah
well yes along that you can those people
that
hi doctors and generate complex talk
about
this is her power hey you need some
water in water sorry some small complete
living body language oh yes so you can
also every so let's say for every
monomial I would hide everyone have a
use conversational with efficient no no
they are the other order of quantifiers
and efficient to simply normal so so
look find there like her you know me in
the index of the new trout is that the
description of alpha is just a point of
integers right so then we'll see just a
sequence of integers the exponent and
what you know so this actor isn't the
normal model you know your favorite
computer power any you know any computer
program takes integers and produces
let's say it's a 01 poonam system has it
will just say 0 is as much the palmar
surface you can add multiply as long as
for number five
and believe some no say no no you will
do products 2 to the M no no it's also
my surface a bit smarter but it should
count on me okay don't think you can
charge it and it doesn't work but they
don't remember what what comes up
surface until you've been an eyewitness
a few well it's time to end this
conference and pence on the other
interns rincon I would like to thank all
the participants fun as the chair of the
GCT luck chef Committee on brm of the
committee I would like to thank all the
speakers for the great terms for all the
participants for their enthusiasm for
making this work surface thank you maybe
we should find our alliance